while new neighbors in a small Wisconsin
town started off as complete strangers
but after learning nothing more than a
name the two women ended up closer than
either could have imagined Elaine
Quijano of our streaming network cbsn
shows us their unbreakable bond Elaine
you told me about the story of so
looking forward to hearing yes I come
bearing good news
get ready pull up a chair when Hilary
Harris's new neighbors moved in next
door her biggest concern was whether
they'd do their part to clean their
shared driveway in the winter but it
turns out there was much more to her
neighbor Don Johnson than she first
realized and that discovery changed both
women's lives forever you know my birth
father is married and Hilary Harris says
she was raised in a loving home by the
couple who adopted her when she was just
a month old but she'd always wondered
about her biological family you wanted
to find them yes I always wanted to find
them it was always in the back of my
mind and I knew the ventually that I
would search when I was ready that
search started in earnest a few years
ago when she and her husband Lance
became pregnant with their daughter
Stella Hilary requested her adoption
records to learn about her family health
history that had all my health history
it had a letter from my birth mother and
it also just closed that my birth father
Wayne had passed away in 2010 and then
it had to have testers Renee and Don and
then right here it says on johnson of
greenwood she found other relatives but
not Don then last year new neighbors
moved in next door
only a shared driveway away the woman's
name dawn from Greenwood Wisconsin do we
really want to share a driveway not
knowing who the neighbors are so we put
a bid in on a fixer-upper house and so
how long after that did you actually
formally meet I don't think we really
formally met I actually formally met her
husband Lance he comes into kam at the
neighbor her name is dawn dawn from
Greenwood I'm like Lance like yeah I'm
like you don't get he's like what are
you talking about him so I went on and
pulled out by all my job some paperwork
and I said dawn Greenwood
it says to hurry hello and he's like oh
my gosh the text came across was who's
your birth father and I said weighing
clothes and then she says text back oh
wow we have a lot to talk about can we
can I call you and I said yes and I was
just pacing pacing back and forth like
it was just how could it be yeah I saw
him pacing when he came here the next
day and I mean just he's like what are
their chances what are the chances you
know and we're all just like really just
couldn't believe that something like
this could even happen
so we're 19 years and three days apart
though dawn and Hillary share a father
Hillary was worried dawn didn't want a
sister she was like did you know are you
mad I'm like I know I'm not mad I said
and I didn't know what was that moment
like Hillary I mean I was so happy to
find her but I'm like okay well this is
seriously not my sisters living next
door to me holy cow this could be why
Stella was so obsessed with her cuz you
know you hear that kids kind of have
that sense or someday intuition and I
remember thinking like that's why you
know in that moment when I first
embraced her in the driveway I mean it
was amazing it was a miracle I love
giving her advice even though she
doesn't want it sometimes but she's
always open minded about it and then
this whole experience has been made us
close I never knew I wouldn't even want
a sister and I am so happy and so
thankful to have her now this discovery
almost did not happen Don says the
closing on their new house was postponed
three times and that they almost walked
away in frustration but she says there
was something about the house that drew
her back to it and I think that just
makes it all the more terrible
it's create what the universe young
these two folks together accidentally
and 65,000 people live in Eau Claire
Wisconsin what are the chances that that
approximate time she would have that
thinking to go to that neighborhood on
that street and that house how about
Stella's intuition Stella on to her
right yeah
joke I said you should go buy a lottery
ticket I love it 31 advice being shared
across the driveway
Elaine a great story thank you thank you